nous sommes ici ce soir à saint laurent
des eaux nous avons en effet choisi
d'être plus concrète pour évoquer cette
affaire de la catastrophe nucléaire
soviétique saint-laurent-des-eaux c'est
l'une des 16 centrales françaises cette
centrale contient deux tranches à eau
sous pression et de transe graphite-gaz
nous le verrons au cours des différents
reportages mais tout de suite
voyons les faits voyons ce qui s'est
passé depuis samedi soir dans la nuit de
samedi à dimanche à la catastrophe
nucléaire de tchernobyl à 130 kilomètres
de kiev en ukraine avec patrick esther
un tout premier document une preuve qui
nous parvient à l'instant une série de
photos réalisées par un satellite civil
américain landsat des images
enregistrées dans l'infrarouge une croix
qui se promènent sur un panache de fumée
et qui nous désignent très clairement un
réacteur un réacteur en fusion sur la
centrale et puis sur une seconde image
enregistrée quelques passages plus tard
par le satellite de carré rouge qui
montre clairement que la caméra du
satellite est saturé par la chaleur
intense qui se dégage là manifestement
deux fois la première qu'on vous montre
à l'instant et la seconde la preuve
qu'un second réacteur est en fusion ce
soir en urss oui moi je tire ici voici
la toute première photo diffusée par la
télévision soviétique en troisième sujet
seulement de leur journal de ce soir le
toit du bâtiment a été pulvérisé par
dégagement de vapeur
cette photo date de plusieurs jours
avant que la catastrophe ne prenne sa
totale dimension je suis sûr qu'il ya eu
beaucoup de morts ce témoignage émane
d'un radioamateurs soviétique habitants
kiev capter cet après midi à tel aviv
j'ai vu des centaines de victimes
arrivés à l'hôpital at il ajouté
ce témoignage confirme donc que la
situation à la centrale nucléaire de
tchernobyl n'est plus contrôlée par les
autorités italiennes
le coeur du réacteur en pomme a bel et
bien fondu dès vendredi dernier
il brûle depuis dimanche la totalité de
l'eau de son circuit de refroidissement
s'est volatilisé en portant la
contamination à des centaines de
kilomètres de là mais sur place la
radioactivité est tel que personne ne
peut plus approcher le réacteur en feu
il est possible que ce soir les trois
autres réacteurs que compte la centrale
soient livrés à eux mêmes privé de
personnel selon des experts américains
le coeur donc d'un second réacteur a
déjà commencé à fondre les soviétiques
qui ne savent pas comment éteindre le
feu en sont réduits à le bombarder avec
du sable mouillé
largués par hélicoptère mais est il
encore possible d'arrêter
l'enchaînement de la catastrophe à
l'intérieur de cette centrale qui était
situé à proximité d'un groupe de
l'habitation
c'est possible si on peut y accéder et
la difficulté vient de ce que l'accès
sans doute très difficile à cause du
niveau de rayonnement résultant
l'accident
les robots d'intervention en milieu
radioactif semble bien dérisoire ce soir
face à la réalité